for anyone with a Honda or Nissan it was
recently proven possible hackers could
unlock or start their vehicles locate
them and raid personal data stored
inside
researchers discovered this latest
vulnerability due to a now fixed flaw in
the car's shared telematics system which
was created by SiriusXM
all that was needed to start the hack
was the car's VIN number from there the
VIN could be sent to a Sirius XM server
to trick it into believing the sender
was the real car owner which then
allowed for several functions to be
performed including turning on the
ignition
this highlighted a weakness of Internet
connected systems in modern vehicles
particularly ones which track vehicle
use and location while hooked up to a
driver's cell phone and taking in user
data
these Technologies are also regularly
being exploited by federal law
enforcement agencies who are investing
more than ever in tools that extract
masses of data from as many as 10 000
different car models
piles of evidence on a potential crime
can now be collected from an automobile
sometimes even more than a smartphone
with much less effort in a recent search
of a 2019 Dodge Charger near the Mexican
border a border agent wrote infotainment
systems were especially useful to
investigators
they could provide information on a
suspect's location email addresses IP
addresses passwords and phone numbers
they could even give insight into things
such as the user's State of Mind
knowledge and motive
however privacy Advocates are sounding
the alarm calling modern cars
surveillance on wheels
the surveillance technology oversight
project also known as stop warned U.S
Customs and Border Patrol and
Immigration and Customs Enforcement are
able to perform sweeping searches with
very easy access to most visited places
family and social contacts call logs and
even social media feeds
stop added while it does not know how
many cars border patrol and Ice have
hacked it can say with confidence that
nearly every new car is vulnerable